hello and welcome to this video playing
international acid are fresh okay banku
again it is really scoring well for me
Raymond coffin okay so what is he doing
with the Banco against the total
non-expert that I am okay so g6 is what
they usually do yeah so the nupe you the
new thing is to simply it don't take on
a six and go for this Queen 85 stuff be
sure Patti to is the the move Bishop b3
black can't even can't take on TV for no
I can take on d5 yes that's the treta
trick ok and here what am i doing d 60
think it's d6 only take later on a six I
am I mistaken i'm probably mistaken here
right yeah should have played bishop e
6861 move earlier maybe about okay
so what he wants to do is what everybody
wants to do in the bangko get an outpost
on d5 that is quite clear um yeah sure
you might get it he might get it quite
often trading Queens us the right choice
in this opening let's try it here with
this one okay hmm it again recently
where this could be punished with the
tactic but this is how I tried to punish
this with a tactic the tactic that
actually didn't work okay maybe he will
move the night away after this no okay
yeah and so a little bit how to believe
that I have enough comp that I should
have enough compensation in this
position but no experimenting in the
opening being a pawn down every game can
can prove to be I can be can be tough
okay here I thought not to be 60
attacking d5 you cannot take these 62 to
that pin yeah that's true but I thought
that isn't that brilliant anyway or
what's the deal here
maybe I'm overlooking stuff don't quite
see it d 5 is somewhat weak now and I'm
threatening stuff I mean maybe I could
have played um differently even okay
what to do here I think I can do this I
mean he can't check here I take you
seven checks check on c3 that doesn't
lead anywhere and I'm attacking d5 a day
for now I think he has over expanded a
little bit him unless I'm overlooking
something note that what what is your
night doing now going back or what just
material up here yeah night has no
square can only go to see three after
which I can grab one beat you I think
yeah now I'm a pawn up and it's a pretty
nice position so queen bee three or
anything else the the ending should be
and quite nice if he trades nope doesn't
right okay
Jagran the only varying worrying thing
is that he would enter with the Queen
somehow but the thing is that I'm
controlling a and B file so it's not
easy to enter my position when you got
the only tool files covered a to open
files covered I it seems that he wants
to go rook you one I can't make that
let's do this chick and I don't know
something like this should be okay white
reasons yeah it's a pretty depressing
position yeah I think you over expended
a little bit down I'm not sure I mean
what white was certainly okay I think I
probably miss plated somewhere around
yeah I think this is probably stronger
taking there immediately you should be
too and maybe then take at Queen a 6 i'm
not sure something is wrong here I think
again the way it went he got a foil and
this should be better for white this I
didn't expect to move but it is
certainly okay yeah and all this is kind
of kind of logical and some somewhere
here I think he needs to improve I mean
maybe okay the engine actually loves at
four so this is correct then but she has
to do something now ok this is this is
true the moment where I've held it
shifts in my favor was e6 Wendy Wendy
six
and then after f5 I'm good yeah the
engine says it's equal after at five but
the thing is he can tape here okay prom
and maybe a five is the thing yeah this
is the thing and all the engine gives f5
and white wins in the attack okay that's
certainly possible f6 is probably the
problem I was thinking that this might
be an option now a good option but now
it takes as good and check this is
leading to check mate check check great
yeah so that's the thing he had to go he
six and he didn't hate it he didn't have
to go his sexy and now I'm fine and the
way he weighed was played it shifted in
my favor Bishop g7 was was now called
for Bishop g7 King takes and Knight c3
which is supposed to be equal according
to the computer which yeah I'm kind of
inclined may be to believe ok now I
cannot take and then we have we repeat a
funny way of drawing yeah and this just
loses after 9a for the night has no
square and here white crumbles and jack
quite quite quickly Jan yeah there was
not a oh oh he resigned in a winning
position Wow after luke t one I don't
have a square I cannot believe it I
totally believed to have deformed oh my
god so look before was completely wrong
I mean okay the engine wants to do this
you can win it with many moves probably
but not with this one oh my god i told i
totally thought i saw luke t one of
course but don't don't ask me why I was
thinking that I have
this is also somewhere where i played is
there was a complete hallucination but
here also loosen ated and just gave up
instead of playing work T 1 oh my hmm
well I had a bill better a better a
bottom bottle of beer earlier rather big
one good beer yeah denied it by a good
friend of mine from France very nice um
and it seems that this beer didn't
really help that much ok guys I hope you
enjoyed this video anyway the lucky win
with a completely yeah surprising
resignation thanks for watching